بود ذكاء اصطناعيه يشغل العالم بعد اتهامه
بانه خطر على البشر وجوله على كلمات سيطرت
على اخبار العالم في 20 22
المجرمه الاحمق في العالم امريكي ساعد
الشرطه الشرطه في القبض عليه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
وجديد اليوم مجدد نقاش قديم جديد ومرجع
الجدل وحوارات قديمه جديده الخبر الجديد
متعلق بشركه اوبن اي اي الرائده بمجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي وبرمجيتها الشهيره
او من كم سنه حتى يعني نقدر نقول انه طرح
وكانت الناس بتدخل وبتطرح على اسئله وبيرد
عادي بيرد عليهم على كل شيء بس لكن نقدر
نقول انه النسخه الجديده متطوره اكثر ف
النسخه الجديده غير انها قادره على
الاجابه على الاسئله هي بتميز لما انت
سائل اسئله مو منطقيه او مستحيل احد
يعرفها كمان ممكن ينطلب منها بمقالات او
نصوص وجربها صحفيين واسد الجامعه وعلقوا
على مستوى النصوص اللي كتبتها في استاذ
مثلا صحافه اعطى البرمجيه واجب من الاعطال
طلابه والبرمجيه كتبت المقال والبروفسير
بيقول انه هذا نص ممكن يعطيه علامه جيد
جدا يعني ومن هنا بندخل للموضوع الجدلي
القديم الجديد لكل بنتكلم عنه النقاشه
المتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي يبرمجياته هل
هي خطر على العقل البشري هل بتخلي الانسان
اذكى وافضل واللي راح تحول لنا الكائنات
اغبى الاجهزه بتعمل عنا كل شيء هل الطلاب
برحمه مثلا يوقفوا يتعلموا وتصير
البرمجيات هذه تعمل لهم دروسهم هل راح
تصير الاجهزه اصلا اذكى مننا
طيب خلينا ننتقل الى دكتور محمد قاسم
الاستشاري في مؤسسه الكويت للتقدم العلمي
اللي هو راح يجاوبنا على هذه الاسئله اهلا
فيك معانا الدكتور محمد حضرتك يعني جاتك
الفرصه انك تجرب هذا ال ااه يعني خلينا
نقول الشات
فاحكي لنا كيف كانت تجربتك الشخصيه
جربتها منها على معلومات عامه جربتها
اسئله واجابات متتاليه جربتها ايضا على
اني اطلب منه يسوي لي برنامج كمبيوتر
فوجئت انه البرنامج متقدم جدا ويستطيع انه
يجاوب كل الاسئله بسهوله مطلقه وبدقه
كبيره لا اقول انه في كل مره نجح فيها
يعني يعطيني اجابه دقيقه لانك انت شيك على
الاجابات
ف- همم يعني في بعض الاجابات كانت خاطئه
لكن اوكي على السؤال يعني بالنسبه للطلاب
يعني هل الطالب يقدر يستفيد منه
[موسيقى]
حتى يعني
تلخيص كتاب وهذا الكتاب وهذا الترخيص مكون
من خمس فقرات
500 كلمه كما يطلب المدرس في الدرس ايه
وفعلا عطاني اياها كما هي ف-
فتجبتي قادر على ان يساهم مع الطلاب وهذه
قد تكون مشكله طيب
مع الطلاب وممكن يكون مشكله ولكن يعني في
نفس الوقت احنا متجهين لا محاله لهذا
الاتجاه فايش همم الفوائد اللي نقدر
نستفيده منها مثلا
يعني طبعا في الفتره الحاليه مثلا
البرمجيات اي شخص يحتاج يبرمج شغله بسيطه
جدا وهو مو متخصص للبرمجه يقدر يطلب منه
ويسوي الى البرنامج وهذا تجربه الكثير من
الناس انه طلبوا اشياء بسيطه لا يحتاج انه
مبرمجه ويدفع فعلا اثنين ممكن مثلا
يعني عندي رايترز بلوك مو قادر اكتب قصه
معينه ممكن اطلب منك فكره حول موضوع معين
يعطيني البذره الاولى وبعدها انتقل لكتابه
شيء معين وهكذا يعني حتى يعني واحده من
الاشياء الجميله انه بدل من اني ابحث على
جوجل وهذا الحين انا قاعد اسويه يعني
واحده من الاشياء اللي كتجربه
علميه غريبه
جدا عن الانف ورحت بحث عنها تاكد وبعدين
حطيتها على تويتر فسوالي كنتنج على تويتر
من غير ما يعرفون الناس ان الكونتز هذا
مولي
احنا خلينا اقول لك الدكتور محمد يعني
اوردي عندنا مشكله انه اريدي صرنا اكسل
رديسيرنا بنعتمد على جوجل في البحث على
طول في اي شيء تقريبا الكتب اصبحت محطوطه
على الجنب قصه سرقه الابحاث والافكار كل
ما لها في ازدياد طيب الان احنا بنجيب
جهاز يعني بيعطينا كل هذه الاشياء يعني
حتى انت لما تكون رايتر بلاك او كاتب عنده
مشكله فكره ويجيء يطلب مساعده من الروبوت
يعني هذه نوعا ما برده يعني سرقه نوعا ما
اخذت يعني يعني ايش ايش صرنا ان احنا في
النهايه وان احنا الانسان المبدع
والرضيعنا نازل
فعلا كلام سليم جدا يعني حتى في حدا وهذا
قبل عده سنوات لما صنعوا برنامج اسمه
الحين لا تذكر الاسم لكن البرنامج عباره
عن
منتج لموسيقى مؤلف لموسيقى فلما اسمعوا
الناس الموسيقى شعره انه وين الانسان هل
الانسان يعني لم يعد المبدع وبدل ذلك
الكمبيوتر هو المبدع هذه طبعا اشكاليه
كبيره لان الحين الكمبيوتر وصل لي الزاويه
الاخيره من قدرات البشر وهي القدره
العقليه وبدا يتدخل في هذا المكان اللي
كنا نحن نشعر انه هذا اللي يجعلنا فوق كل
شيء على الكره الارضيه فالان شنو اللي
يسوي في هذا يعني حتى انا سالت همم نفسي
باللغه العربيه
شنو هل الطالب ممكن يستفيد منك وياخذ
المعلومات ويكتب مقالات
بالتاكيد يقدر ولكن هذا لا يعني انه راح
يتعلم بعمق همم ياخذ المعلومات بعمق وعليه
ان يحذر ايضا ان قد تكون بعض المعلومات
اللي اعطيه اياها
مستوعب هذا الموضوع بس ما حد ما في اي احد
في مرحله دراسيه ويكون طالب حيستوعب هذا
الموضوع يعني الواحد بده يخلص طب يعني انا
صراحه عندي مشكله اخلاقيه صراحه دكتور
محمد معلم الموضوع
متفق انا تماما انه هناك مشكله اخلاقيه
ليست فقط على مستوى ابداعات البشريه انما
حتى على الوظائف اللي راح تبقى مستقبلا
وحاضرا حتى يعني مثلا كثير من البرامج
الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم تستطيع ان ترسم
رسمات افضل من الكثير من البشر حول الكره
الارضيه
بمجرد انك اعطينا كلمات يعطيك الرسمه اللي
تبينها وهذا انا استخدمتها تجربتها يعني
شوف يعني اعطيتش مثال قبل فتره كنت اطلب
من برنامج الكمبيوتر عفوا اطلب من الناس
على الانترنت
للروبوتات
[موسيقى]
اا الخبر الثاني من نفس عالم الذكاء
الاصطناعي هذا مثير جدا للجدل ايضا وهذه
المره متعلق بالروبوتات فمجلس بلديه سان
فرانسيسكو صوت على تبني قرار بالسماح
لعناصر شرطتها باستخدام روبوتات قادره على
القتل والنيه استخدامها في حالات هجمات
الارهابيه او عمليات القتل الجماعه
المتحكم فيها عن بعد يعني والقرار الجديد
بين النص على تزويد هذه الروبوتات بعبوات
ناسفه وغيرها من الاسلحه اللي تعيق او
تربك اي مسلحه او مجرم رغم انه القرار
بنصف على استخدام الروبوتات في القتل في
الحاله الطارق فقط وانه يمكن كبار عناصر
الشرطه فقط من اصدار الاوامر للروبوتات
قلنا راح تستخدم لانقاذ الابرياء لكن هذا
طبعا ابدا الجدل اللي فتحوا الموضوع ففي
وقت الشرطه والسلطه بتقول انه هذا هو الحل
الاخير امام ما في وجهه ازاي الجماعي في
ناس كمان في نفس الوقت جالسه بتهاجم
القرار تماما وشايفه انه ممكن يزيد من عنف
رجال الشرطه هذا غير النقاش طبعا المتعلق
باخلاقيه تمكين اله من القتل والناس اللي
شايفه انه استخدام للتكنولوجيا في اسوا
صوره خليني ارجع لك دكتور محمد قاسم
الاستشاري في مؤسسه الكويت للتقدم العلمي
يعني فعليا دكتور محمد ايش رايك في هذا
النوع من الروبوت القاتل
طبعا بالتاكيد هذا التوجه راح يتحقق لا
مجال للتراجع واذا ما سويت امريكا راح
تسويه الصين روسيا الدول هذه كلها بهذا
الاسم
هو كيف ممكن نتحكم في الموضوع بحيث انه ما
يضر البشر يعني حاليا على فكره الروبوتات
مستخدمه وقد استخدم روبوت في 2016 وكان
ايضا معه عبوه ناسفه فاذا بالامكان او
استخدم هذا الشيء في السابق ولكن كان في
علاقه قيود
دكتور محمد وصلح لي هذا الشيء يعني
بيستخدم روبوتات في تفكيك المتفجرات ايضا
بالضبط تفكيك المتفجرات وايضا حتى استخدام
متفجر لانقاذ البشر فهذا الشغله ممكن تصير
لحمايه الشرطه لان احيانا وقد حدث يعني
قبل الفتره بسيطه انه شخص دخل على مدرسه
فيها طلاب والشرطه و بتصوير يعني كامل
الشرطه من خوفهم ما دخلوا على
المجرم هذا ولم يوقفوه وقتل الكثير من
الناس فهذا يعني يعطي نوع من الحمايه
للشرطه وايضا يعطي حمايه للناس اللي همم
ممكن يقتله في حاله مثل الحالات هذه فهي
شوفي يعني في نقاش كبير جدا على هذا
الموضوع لكن لا زال يعني احنا ما قعدنا
نتكلم عن الذكاء اصطناعي ان الروبه مستقل
بذاته او يحمل سلاح ويرمي في كل مكان انما
لا يزال هناك تحكم من البشر وانا صراحه
اتمنى اذا فعلا حققه هذا الشيء انه يحطون
عليه ذكاء اصطناعي يتعرف على البشر حتى
يتاكد قبل لا يقوم همم
لي انه في وسط خصوصا لما بنتكلم ان احنا
على مثلا الاحداث ذي اللي بتحدث الهجمات
هذه اللي في المدارس والاشياء دي كده هذه
بيدخل الحامل بالنابل فيها يعني بيكون
مثلا مطلق النار بين الطلاب بين كده كيف
التمييز يصير يعني ما انت ممكن يروح عندك
ضحيه يعني كده علماشي
ولذلك يومين
فقط هو اللي اتخذ القرار في هذا الموضوع
في ان مثلا يرمي القنبله او حتى استخدام
هذا النوع من الروضه طبعا انا مو قاعد
ادافع عنها يعني يمكن من طريقه كلامي انا
قاعد ادافع عن روبك لا بالعكس انا اعتقد
ان مثل هذه الاشياء يجب ان تدرس لانه ما
عندنا دراسات
حتى في الحرب تستخدم فكيف بها الان
تدخلونها الى صفوف والطلاب اذا صارت حادثه
من الحوادث اللي بتصير عاده خصوصا في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامر وايد
صعب محتاجه الى دراسه وفهم وتاكيد حتى قبل
لا نستخدم مثل هذه الاشياء اللي لم تتجرب
في السابق
الان لما نيجي نتكلم في كل هذه المواضيع
وحضرتك ذكرت قال ايجابيات والسلبيات
ودائما في سؤال حول الاخلاقيه استخدام هذه
الاشياء يعني اكيد ما هنتسال عن اخلاقيه
مثلا
ينظف البيت هذا يا سلام كثير منه مثلا
يعني بس الاشياء الثانيه لا عليها علامات
استفهام كبيره مين اللي هيجيء ويجلس يتحكم
في هذا القرار نعمل او ما نعمل هل مثلا
يعني زي الماسك ما بيعمل اليوم في تويتر
مثلا
هذا السؤال جدا رائع يعني بالنسبه لهذه في
مؤسسات انا اتذكر يعني
في بعض المؤسسات موجوده في امريكا تحاول
ان همم تبحث في اخلاقيات هذا الموضوع حتى
تتاكد من ان ما يصير مشاكل الاخلاقيه
وللعلم يعني بس على السريع داخل نقطه انه
حتى الروبوتات اللي تنظف البيت هم فيها
اخلاقيات والناس يحبوني يتاكدون قبل لا
يدخل الروضه للبيت ويؤذي مثلا كبار السن
ممكن الروابطيهم عن طريق ان هو حامل سلاح
لكن حتى حمله السكين او شيء هذا ممكن
يقعدني البشر اللي موجودين المساله هذه
هناك مؤسسات شغاله على الموضوع هناك
محاولات لتشريحها الشركات نفسها ايضا
قاعده تضع مجموعه من المختصين والخبراء في
الاخلاقيات حتى يدرسوا هذا الموضوع بس
احنا لازمنا يعني قاعدين نشوف ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي او امور تكنولوجيه من هذا النوع
قاعده تسبق الاخلاق يعني احنا كل واحد
وبتكنولوجيا وايد اسرع من الاخلاق اللي
احنا قاعدين نشوف همم يعني ردت فعل هنا
وهناك وغير متكامله غير واضحه
والتكنولوجيا تطلع ثم بعد ذلك تعال خلينا
نمسك
الشيء البعبع المرعب هذا اللي طلع في كل
شيء يعني صراحه بس سؤال سريع على هذا
النوع من المؤسسات اللي بتتحدث عنه هل هي
موجوده في العالم العربي ايضا ولا لا
المؤسسات اللي شفتها هي موجوده في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يعني غالبا هي هناك اذن وهناك حاجه بس
احنا بنشكرك على هذا
المداخله كان معنا الدكتور محمد قاسم
استشاري في مؤسسه الكويت التقدم العلمي
شكرا لك دكتور
25 يوم بتفصلنا عن نهايه 20 22 وحقيقه
يعني كانت سنه حافله بالاحداث وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه اعطتنا ملخص للسنه عن
طريق جوله على 10 كلمات او عبارات تصدرت
الاخبار هذه السنه خلونا ناخذ هذه اللفه
مع بعض اولا نهايه العالم
عن حرب عالميه ثالثه العالم
من اكثر العبارات المسيطره هذه السنه
توثيق كلمه ثانيه سمعناها حتى يعني ملينا
منها بصراحه في الاخبار هذه السنه والسبب
طبعا قصه شراء اللمسك لتويتر بكل تعقيدات
او مراحلها والكلام كثير عن شروط توثيق
الحسابات الجديده والوان وانواع الجديده
للتوثيق وقبل كل هذا طبعا الرسوم اللي
يبغى يفردها الثمانيه دولارات هذه اللي
قلبت العالم امراه حريه او امراه حياء
حريه هذا كان شعار الاحتجاجات المولع في
ايران من شهور من وقت مقتل الشاب مهسا
اميني على يد شرطه الاخلاق وهذه العباره
كمان تحولت لشعار ابعد من ايراني من محلي
ومن حول العالم صارت بتستخدم للدعم في همم
الاحتجاجات والمحتاجين والعباره كانت كمان
من العبارات اللي سيطرت على الاخبار في 20
22 ومع هذه العباره كمان كان في كلمه
ثانيه متعلقه باحتجاجات ماليه الاخبار
السنه وهي اوراق اي 4 لكن هذه الاحتجاجات
كانت في الصين وتحديدا ضد جديد اجراءات
كرونه من جديد فسار متظاهرين بيحملوها
دليل على غياب حريه التعبير في بلادهم
وحتى اون لاين صاروا الصينيين بينزلوا
الصور مربعات يا دليل انه يعني مو مسموح
لهم يقولوا شيء وطبعا وفاه الملكه
اليزابيث بعد 70 سنه حكم كانت من دون شك
من ابرز احداث السنه ومع وفاتها جسر لندن
كان من اكثر العبارات المتصدره للاخبار
لانه عمليه جسر لندن اوبريشن لندن بردج هو
اسم الخطه الموضوعه من سنين واللي بتناول
خطوه بخطوه وبتضمن الاحداث التاليه
والمحدده لمراسم وفاه الملكه
[موسيقى]
الله
الفاشيه الجديده كانت من العبارات
المتصدره كمان في 20 22 وسببها وصول حزب
فلتر الذي تاليا اخوه ايطاليا اليمين
المتطرف في الانتخابات التشريعيه وصولهم
للحكم ومع صارت جورج ملوني اول امراه تقود
الحكومه الايطاليه وطلعت تقارير عن
اعجابها وحبها للممثلين وفي امريكا ايضا
اذا انتقلنا الى هناك حنلاقي انه منح
المحكمه العليا كل ولايه حقها في حظر
عمليات الاجهاض او لا او اللي صار بعدها
من قرار 20 ولايه حظر الاجهاض واهميه هذا
الموضوع في السياسه الامريكيه اصلا
والانتخابات كل هذا خلى عبارات رو ضد من
اللي تصدر هذه السنه وهو اسم قضيه صدر
فيها حكم في
1973 بانه دستور الولايات المتحده
والدستور الولايات المتحده عفوا يحمي حريه
المراه الحامل في اختيار الاجهاض دون قيود
حكوميه وهذا هو الحكم اللي الغى السلام
وايضا عندنا مع حرب روسيا واوكرانيا وازمه
الطاقه في اوروبا توفير استهلاك الطاقه
كانت عباره سمعناها في الاخبار كثير في 20
22 همم يعني بس تحديدا هذه السنه كانت سنه
اظهرت تسارع في التداعيات الكارثيه لازمه
المناخ وفي قمه المناق الشهر الماضي في
شرم الشيخ في اتفاق وصف بالتاريخ تم
التوصل اليه بشان صندوق اتسمى بالخسائر
والاضرار وبيهدف لي تعويض الخسائر
والاضرار المناخيه اللي بتعانيها الدول
الاكثر فقرا هذا الشيخ الخسائر والاضرار
من اكثر الاشياء اللي سمعناها في الاخبار
في سنه 20 22
حديث عن المناخ ما هننسى اكيد نتكلم عن
الجنون اللي شفناها هذه السنه منهجمات
واعتداء واحتجاجات غريبه من الشطاء المناخ
والبيئه وحول العالم والكثير من الاحيان
كان ضحيتها اعمل فنيه كبيره وخالده وكثير
منها اعتمدت على القاء حساء الطماطم على
لوحات فنيه وعلشان كده حساء الطماطم او
شوربه الطماطم كانت جمله سمعناها في 20 22
اكثر من اي سنه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
في مثل بيقولوا الدبور زن على خراب عشه
هذا تحديدا اللي صار مع مجرم هارب من
العداله اسمه كريستوف سبورت في ولايه
جورجيا الامريكيه واللي ممكن نسميه يعني
بكل كده نسميه المجرم الاحمر لانه مكتب
الشرطه في المقاطعه اللي ساكن فيها نشر
على فيسبوك لا احد دوريه بينشروها ويعبر
عن اهم 10 مطلوبين لشهر نوفمبر علشان
تساعدهم الناس في القبض عليهم او الابلاغ
بمعلومات عنهم الاخذ زكي كريستوفر يبدو
انه الغرور اخذوه ونزعاج كيف هو من اهم او
اكثر 10 مطلوبين مش هذا الكلام يعني فجام
معلق على البوست كتب لهم طب وانا انه
باقول لكم
هبل الحماقه قامت الشرطه ما كذبت خبر وردت
عليه على طول وقالت له معك حق في مذكرتين
قبض بحقك واحنا في الطريق الي عندك وفعلا
وصلوا له وقبضوا عليه الناس الشرطه نشرت
سكرين شوت من البوس والكومنت وفهمت الناس
انه لائحه المطلوبين الاهم مو معناها انهم
الوحيدين لكن هدول الاخضر او اللي عليهم
تهم اكثر لكن مو معنى هذا ابدا انه باقي
المطلوبين ما بندور عليهم وعلى فكره شكرا
كريستوفر كمان انه ساعدهم يقبضوا عليه
ونبهوا كمان الناس انه اللي مو عارف لو في
امر بالقبض عليه او لا يتفضل يرن علينا او
يبعث لنا ايميل يعني روحي ورط نفسه طيب
مشاهدينا وصلنا لنهايه حلقه اليوم
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]